brad pitt is accusing his ex-wife
angelina jolie of trying to inflict harm
on him and his interests in their
chateau miraval winery that's life isn't
it a new legal docs filed in los angeles
on friday pitts lawyers claim jolie sold
her stake in their winery to russian
oligarch yuri scheffler in an effort to
damage his involvement in the company
but how did this legal battle all begin
well it started in february when pitt
first sued jolie over the sale of her
shares of mirror ball he was seeking
monetary damages legal fees and wanted
her sail to scheffler to be voided and
now in the latest docks pitt's attorneys
claim that she sought to inflict harm on
him and alleges that she knew and
intended that scheffler and his
affiliates would try to control the
business pitt had built and to undermine
pitt's investment in miraval the docs
also claimed that the vineyard became
pitt's passion and grew into a
multi-million dollar business as for
jolie well he alleges she contributed
nothing to miraval's success and since
scheffler who owns spy group the parent
company behind many alcohol brands
obtained a stake in miraval he's
allegedly launched a hostile takeover of
the wine business and get this the docs
also allege that jolie has not returned
to the vineyard since the two filed for
divorce in 2016. and according to pitt's
lawsuit back in february he claimed that
per the terms of their divorce which was
finalized in 2019 the couple had a
mutual understanding that neither of
them could sell off their interest in
the winery without the other's consent
e.t has reached out to jolie's reps for
comment
[Music]